tulsi gabbard and rand paul are among
individuals in the united states put on
a list of russian propagandists by
ukraine now it's always important to
understand that
one person's propagandist is another
person's truth-teller so even if you or
in this particular case i happen to
agree with this designation we have to
remember that this is perspective this
is the perspective of ukraine and
without question tulsi gabbard and rand
paul have sort of so doubt about the
validity of the ukrainian cause and um
minimized the pernicious nature of putin
and his regime so it's important to
understand that but let's look here uh
at a couple
of the reasons why they are on this list
understanding that it is all of course
subject to interpretation and then i'll
give you my opinion now first real quick
i want to tell you about our sponsor
myheritage i love tracking my genealogy
and dna and there's just this sort of
reality that if your ancestors are
jewish and they were moving around due
to political circumstances before and
during world war ii
it can just be really tough to figure
out
from most records sort of like where
you're from and that's one of the great
things about the dna test by myheritage
which was able to give me a more
detailed breakdown than any other test
on the market i sent my heritage a quick
cheek swab
it opened me up to all sorts of
fascinating discoveries about my family
you get a breakdown of your origins
across 42 ethnicities in over 2 100
geographic regions you can find new
family members who match to your dna i
trust my heritage with my privacy
because of their policy
of never selling or licensing your data
period
you remain the owner of your data my
results
not shockingly
98.8 percent ashkenazi jewish of origins
in poland and ukraine and russia and
romania all of which i knew about but
also hungary germany east and central
europe i did not know about that and
also 1.2 percent english which is pretty
interesting i've been using my heritage
for years to connect with cousins and
other people
and now i also have the dna information
and it's fascinating start making
exciting discoveries about your own
origins get free shipping on your dna
kit when you use my link in the
description and use the code pacman
okay so tulsi and rand paul on the list
of russian propagandists kentucky
senator rand paul and former hawaii
representative tulsi gabbard have been
listed by ukraine among a number of
american politicians academics and
activists kiev claims have promoted
russian propaganda
the list was compiled by the ukrainian
center for countering disinformation
founded in 2021 by ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky to study the impact of
russian disinformation the center is
part of the national security and
defense council who else is on the list
uh u.s army colonel douglas mcgregor
military strategist edward lutwack
political scientist john mear shimer and
journalist gren greenwald does not
explain what the consequences are for
those who ukraine clearly considers
responsible for promoting the kremlin's
line but it offers explanations for
inclusion on the list in april rand paul
said joe biden provoked russia to invade
its neighbor by advocating ukraine's
entrance into nato
um he also said you could argue the
countries they've attacked were part of
russia or part of the soviet union
tulsi gabbard said the u.s provoked
putin for many years and that there are
25 dangerous bio labs in ukraine which
could release deadly pathogens now we
extensively covered that clip that tulsi
did and the claims are
some are untrue
some are true but lack context some are
true but are not remarkable in that
there are bio labs all over europe uh
and it was a real sort of red herring
very very strange the bio labs claims
have also been supported by greenwald
who ukraine says didn't want the us to
help ukraine
to avoid provoking russia into a nuclear
war so listen what's the bottom line
here uh i you all know i am no fan of
rand paul
uh tulsi gabbard or glenn greenwald
and i do believe that they have been
more sympathetic to it's i it's weird to
even call it the russian cause it's like
they've just been more sympathetic to
russian propaganda
uh than i am comfortable with
but at the same time i believe that they
are relatively mild propagandists in the
sense of having much of an impact in
steering public opinion or whatever the
case may be
greenwald and tulsi
are sort of particularly dangerous in
that
they still i think are trying to trick
people into thinking that they're on the
left when very clearly they're just kind
of reactionary
faux populists of sorts
and that is the bigger picture which to
me is kind of a concern that there are
still people bamboozled i still have
people who write to me saying tulsi is
the only real liberal left in the
democratic party first of all she
she i don't even know that she's in the
democratic party um and moreover she
certainly is not espousing any
progressive values so in terms of uh you
know whether i think that there should
be serious consequences for this or
whatever absolutely not they are just
giving their opinion i don't have any
evidence that they are paid
propagandists in any way but sometimes
people become useful idiots and i know
whenever i say that people say oh ad
hominem ad hominem no no it's a very
particular term
a useful idiot is someone who is
unknowingly supporting a cause with
which they may not agree or may not be
trying to support i don't know that
tulsi and greenwald are actually useful
idiots because i think they know the
cause they're trying to support but they
are becoming useful idiots in a very
narrow sense that some people still
think they're on the left and they go
well if tulsi says it
if uh if greenwald says it then a i must
be on the left if i agree because
they're on the left when really they're
not they're just
sort of reactionary instruments at this
point
being cynically uh
cynically used and sometimes willingly
promoting what i think are just bad
causes i think that russia's invasion of
ukraine was not provoked i think it was
wrong call me crazy uh doesn't mean
anything in particular about any other
conflict or dispute so there it is and
of course there's always blowback and so
now thanks to tulsi and greenwald and
rand paul being on this list
now
it will further amplify claims
that
there is a sort of concerted effort to
discredit them or whatever they're just
saying things that don't make any sense
and obviously ukraine is biased in
creating this list without a doubt
but these are individuals saying things
that make no sense and for that they do
deserve to be called out